genau wir wollen Nachfragen nach einer
politischen Einordnung aus Deutschland
und zwar bei den cdu-partei und
Fraktionsvorsitzenden Friedrich Merz ihn
erstmal einen guten Morgen guten Morgen
wie ist ihre Reaktion auf die aktuelle
Ereignisse
natürlich ein Schock es ist Krieg in
Europa es ist nicht nur ein Krieg gegen
die Ukraine sondern es ist ein Krieg
gegen die Demokratie gegen unsere
Freiheit und das ist doch das nach
meiner Einschätzung sehr rationale
Kalkül von Putin es ist nicht die NATO
die ihn bedroht das ist ein propans der
russischen Propaganda schon seit vielen
Wochen und Monaten Putin fühlt sich
bedroht durch die Demokratiebewegung in
der Ukraine fühlt sich bedroht durch die
Demokratie Bewegung in Belarus und wenn
Sie einmal die historischen Abläufe der
letzten Wochen Monate vielleicht der
letzten zwei Jahre sehen dann hat ja die
Verschärfung der Tonlage bei Putin in
dem Augenblick begonnen wo es
monatelange Proteste gegen die
gefälschten Wahlen in Belarus gegeben
hat und das ist nach meiner Einschätzung
das Motiv nicht die NATO Putin weiß dass
die NATO ihn nicht bedroht die NATO
bedroht niemanden das schien aber er hat
große Angst davor dass sein politisches
System in Russland und sein Umfeld
bedroht werden durch die freiheits- und
Demokratie Bewegungen in seiner
Nachbarschaft und gegen die führt er
jetzt krieg es ist Krieg in Europa
noch die von der EU verhängten
Sanktionen die Putin aber offenbar wenig
beeindruckt haben waren die Sanktionen
zu schwach
bis zum vergangenen Wochenende waren sie
nach meiner Einschätzung richtig sie
waren vor allen Dingen geschlossen
vorgetragen von Europa und auch aus den
Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika es wird
jetzt sicherlich eine Verschärfung
dieser
Sanktionsregime geben geben müssen
eine militärische Intervention in der
Ukraine das haben ihre Korrespondenten
ja gerade aus Washington aus Brüssel
übereinstimmt so berichtet diese
Einschätzung teile ich wird es nicht
geben aber es wird eine weitgehende
Isolierung Russlands geben
diplomatisch politisch aber auch
ökonomisch wirtschaftlich ich rechne
damit dass die russischen Banken in
Europa und in der Welt außerhalb
Russlands jetzt geschlossen werden ich
rechne damit das auch harte Sanktionen
in einzelnen Wirtschaftszweigen erfolgen
und ich will das hier ausdrücklich an
dieser Stelle sagen wir werden als
cdu/csu und auch als Bundestagsfraktion
die Bundesregierung auch die Europäische
Union diesen Bemühungen unterstützen es
wird jetzt hier keine innenpolitische
Diskussion über dieses Thema geben
sondern allenfalls intensive Beratungen
so wie sie übrigens diese Woche auch
schon stattgefunden haben und das
allerwichtigste was jetzt erreicht
werden muss und ich bin sicher wir
werden es erreichen ist eine große
Geschlossenheit der westlichen
Staatengemeinschaften auch der
Demokratien der Welt gegen diesen
Angriff auf die Demokratie und ich bin
sicher dass dies gelingen wird und zwar
unterhalb der Schwelle militärischer
Intervention sie hatten vor wenigen
Tagen noch gesagt Freiheit müssen
notfalls auch militärisch verteidigt
werden verstehe ich sie richtig dass das
jetzt nicht mehr geht
unverändert und diese Freiheit wird
verteidigt vom nato-bündnis dass
nato-bündnis umfasst auch osteuropäische
Staaten wie Polen und die baltischen
Staaten und die Bundeswehr ist in
einigen Teilen dort schon stationiert
ich gehe davon aus dass dort jetzt auch
weitere truppenstationiert werden und
wir sollten hier auch innenpolitisch
sehr klar und deutlich sagen wir werden
jede Maßnahme unterstützen auch als
Union die darauf ausgerichtet ist dass
NATO Territorium vor weiteren
Übergriffen Russlands zu schützen wenn
notwendig auch militärisch hier zählt
jetzt Abschreckung und meine feste
Überzeugung ist dass diese Abschreckung
Wirkung haben wird putin wird
wahrscheinlich die gesamte Ukraine
versuchen zu kontrollieren aber er wird
dieses Risiko auch für ihn persönlich
nicht eingehen dass NATO Territorium
auch zusätzliche anzugreifen und dieses
nato-territorium werden wir gemeinsam
schützen auch
sag der cdu-partei und
Fraktionsvorsitzende Friedrich Merz
vielen Dank für ihre Einordnung hier
live im ZDF Morgenmagazin danke schön